welcome to a big part of your democratic
process yes the exit poll it's pretty
simple you vote you leave the voting
booth and a pollster approaches you and
asks a simple question so who did you
vote for exit polls are used in
elections all over the world and can
help provide important information about
voters namely who they're voting for as
well as things like your age sex
religion ethnicity marital status and
occupation but critics say that the exit
poll can sometimes hurt the democratic
process more than actually help it by
jumping the gun exit polls and national
elections rely heavily on the East Coast
where voting starts and ends earlier in
the rest of the United States and the
media starts reporting on what exit
polls are showing meaning voters in
California or Hawaii who are amongst the
last to vote can be influenced or even
deterred from voting if they think
there's already a winner like for
example in 2004 exit polls predicted
John Kerry could kick George Shelby Bush
out of the oval office and we know how
that turned out so how much attention
should we even be paying to the exit
polls